I'm afraid I have to inform you you're
all fired
security will be coming around now why
because my dad told me to
in this episode Kendall shuts down vol 2
which you know if you saw the first
season this was a sort prized
acquisition that he captained the
strategy of acquiring it's interesting
to me that you know he's been through a
tragedy he's in this submissive
relationship with his dad but maybe
there's some freedoms you get with being
submissive to and they you can do some
tough stuff if you feel like you're not
responsible anymore so no you go there's
a big taboo against spitting in people's
faces that's like one of the most sort
of weirdly intimate horrible things you
can see Jeremy approached it with this
typical rigor and no doubt that he
wanted the acting scene partner to do
that to him and do as many times as we
needed and credit to him because I think
it's a good scene great to have you boy
I just hope that there's no weirdness
without fuzzy boundaries if you want to
go fast go alone if you want to go far
go together when we were thinking about
who would be the head of a TN that Tom
would find himself up against we're just
interested in the sort person who could
manage this very tough news organization
when we managed to cast Jena Berlin it
clicked into place we serve a
demographic of highly intelligent
viewers who are really tired of being
patronized elsewhere by latte-sipping
douche bags with hundred dollar haircut
yes she's tough she could cope with this
and she believes in it as well it's not
like Tom he's kind of slightly trying on
the trousers of that organisation she
kind of lives and breathes it
thank you very much and [ __ ] you and
I'll catch up with you later
not on your dying day baby
[Music]
you